hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar how to advance cell and gene
therapies with an innovative flexible
approach
i am marie stone of labroots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by default systems to learn more
visit
3ds.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
quest question box and click send
all questions will be answered via email
following the broadcast today
you may also submit any technical
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
chris andrews senior solution consultant
at the salt systems and domenico
palumberry solution
consultant at the salt systems
chris and domenico you may now begin
your presentation
good day everyone my name is christopher
andrews i am a solution consultant with
desol system
and joining me today is my colleague
domenico palumberry hi everyone i'm
solution consultant for the sol system
and covering life science
thanks domenico
we're going to be talking to you today
about advancing cell and gene therapies
from
the beginning of the drug discovery
phase all the way through
commercial manufacturing and how you can
improve those
various stages of that manufacturing
development process
through innovative robust flexible
solutions
so we're going to start
with domenico
yes thanks so the cell engine therapy
market is having a boom recently i mean
you can see here the number or cell
engine
therapies launched globally by the year
i mean it's growing a lot and as well
like the sales growth trends is
is growing a lot and there are like
really nice prediction from now to the
2024.
well the sales trajectory is is
skyrocketing
we're also seeing that the cost of
manufacturing these products is also
going up
um and the types of companies that are
that are getting into selling gene
therapy aren't always the
pharma giants they're oftentimes much
smaller companies
molecule shops as they're sometimes
called
and uh
having the resources to be able to
make those products efficiently cost
effectively
is uh
is going up as well and it's it's very
difficult to do
yes indeed and this is completely
related with the difficulty of the
process itself as you as we can see in
the next slide i mean
this the manufacturing process is first
of all a huge collaborative
test you know in which like you need to
collaborate between academia r d
institutional hospitals cdmo uh pharma
and as well like patients so i mean
looking at this scenario already i mean
we can see that the collaboration is a
key component of this manufacture we go
and we see the step over the difficult
of the different uh
of the manufacturing cell engine therapy
it's very complicated because you start
with apheresis that can be from patient
or like or donor you froze down the
cells you put an airplane and you send
to the pharma where start the cell
modification right usually with a viral
vector viral vector that are arriving
maybe from your collaborator from a cdmo
and gmo
so you genetically modify the cells and
after the step you start the expansion
and the harvest of this cells when you
finish all of these you have like all
the quantity
assurance and testing that you need to
to do on on this cells at the end you
froze down back and you sent to the
hospital when there will be the infusion
today to the final patient so
i mean it's a very long process it's a
very complicated process think about
that the first one is around 24 days
just to give like some numbers from the
beginning
to the end so i mean this requires like
a lot of effort in sense of a lot of
scientists working on it working in a
controlled environment as well for
example clean room or isolators so
working very
very tight between them with a huge
responsibility on the shoulder because
at the end if something gets wrong i
mean the patient will not receive the
therapy itself
indeed
and this is a highly specialized process
this is different than
any other type of uh
drug product that that is made
at scale
um
in the industry so uh
there's been some learning that's been
happening at the same time as the
development
of these products has uh has gone on
right
um if you look at the typical stages
of uh of the therapeutic manufacturing
or or from conception all the way to to
essentially the patient arm
you've got these major phases you've got
the the basic research that happens drug
discovery it will go to pre-clinical for
for um dosage uh studies and for uh for
um tolerability studies then it'll go to
human trials and then it will eventually
go to commercial manufacturing
a lot of that happens in a much more
compressed
time frame
with cell and gene therapies basic
research and drug discovery can be more
focused with cell and gene therapies
because you've got a target indication
that you're looking for maybe it's a
gene sequence that you know that you
need to alter in order to um deliver the
therapeutic to the patient um however
that is an extremely costly and
time-consuming process um even when you
do know what your your therapeutic
target is
um uh
with that genotype um so having a
software solution that can reduce the
complexity of that challenge uh finding
candidate processes or molecules or
whatever that would be amenable to that
uh to that therapy can be greatly
reduced um if you've got a target uh
performance profile or certain
attributes
whether it's you know the end viscosity
of that
infusion or you know a binding infinity
for a particular
molecular target
you can use software you can use a
solution to reduce that complexity uh
and then bring you further into those
later stages
um
being able to go
from
uh preclinical onto clinical being able
to scale up those batches
uh
from just the test article to something
that's larger scale for a larger patient
population
that's going to require a lot of
documentation it's going to require a
lot of data
particularly once it gets into the human
scale or the human scope
having
data traceability and document
traceability
and also making sure that all procedures
have been followed along the way that's
absolutely critical
for getting things
past those regulatory hurdles but also
ensuring patient safety
increase do you think that the paper can
be an efficient method in order to to
follow all these procedures
unfortunately
i'd have to say it's not an efficient uh
way of doing these things but it is
extremely common even in the very large
pharma companies
um you're still seeing paper batch
records being captured
paper being exchanged even within groups
within the same company and often these
smaller
cell and gene therapy type
companies
are relying heavily on their partners
contract manufacturing organizations
contract research organizations and
though those
entities may individually be using
digital systems they're not talking to
each other so you have a lot of siloed
data so having something that will
enable collaboration would really make
the difference especially for you know
the patients that are relying on these
therapeutics
yeah and let's think about the
compliance i mean look at this like i
mean the recent fda compliance you
should fall into the master my
majority follow into these five
categories right and all of these five
categories are related to usage of paper
so think about how
i mean a usage of a digital solution can
help to be compliant with a with
regulation
yes indeed
so you've got the compliance challenge
in terms of
following procedures
documenting that data traceability
and in gmp manufacturing as well uh
there are certain challenges that come
along with that um
creating those those protocols creating
those sops that go along with your
process being able to maintain and make
sure that they're current and that
they're matching the actual process that
is in use
being able to store these records that
you're generating whether it's your
quality system your learning management
system for the procedures but also the
data that's being generated as part of
the manufacturing process
sample tracking
and chain of custody as it goes through
um all of that is absolutely critical in
the cell and gene therapeutic space
because you know oftentimes if it's
autologous cell transplants uh you you
have to have
you know the identity that the the cells
are going right back to that donor
again we talked about siloed data it's
making it very difficult for for people
to to work efficiently
to
have that data traceability
yeah because let me say one thing about
this
i mean
talking about paper right but some of
the companies start digitalization of
course i mean but they have
different pieces of software all around
these different pieces of software
cannot talk between them so the data
that are gained from
transfer to another solution this
results in data that are not usable
anymore and this means a lot of richness
that
is uh is going away you know because
that analysis is like i mean a richness
of of a company
indeed so yeah they don't have the whole
story they're not able to
to make their
their full submission or get the most
value out of the information that
they've actually generated
so but
our digital solution can help like a ga
cell engine therapy manufacturing
especially in gxp environment the first
thing is helping with writing procedures
so helping writing down the sops sops
must be written down in a universal
language so for example following s88
standard so in order to improve
collaboratives so you can send out to
your collaborate to you know to
you can send out to your collaborators
like the the protocols and they can read
because it is in the same format after
that you need to be sure that what you
are writing down in the sop is executed
in a good way by scientists scientists
are working under a lot of pressure they
are they they know that if they wrong
the the therapy will not be delivered to
the patient they are working in a clear
room or using isolators so in very tight
conditions so they have a huge pressure
on them so everything that they can
facilitate
the execution of the sop is important
and how can we facilitate the execution
first of all in a step-by-step execution
in which the scientists can just follow
what to do automatically and embed the
calculation for example so that they
will allow do the scientists do not stop
and do calculation but just to follow
the procedure and the instruments that
are directly interconnected with the
with the software itself so for example
if i'm running my fax analysis the
results of the number of positive cells
will arrive directly to my software and
from there i can proceed today to the
next step
and this is not important suggested for
execution so to reduce the human error
of course but it's important as well for
the compliance because as we know all
the documentation is very important for
like for compliance reason right every
step must be recorded audit trailer must
be
created and all the raw data must be
saved for every step of this
and
in when you work in gxp condition it's
not just this you need to take care as
well of all the metrology
all the logbooks you know and already
avoiding all of that job to the
operators to the scientists is a great
advantage
another important point is that all of
the solution must be easy to be deployed
so must be easy there must be an easy
implementation of the solution because
scientists must work on science must not
work on it solution implementing a
dissolution right
yeah definitely uh you want the solution
to fit your process you don't have to
have that learning curve be so high that
ultimately the users aren't going to use
the solution and then that will open you
up for a non-compliance
and you know it's a risk to data
integrity
the other thing also you want to be able
to collaborate doing analytics right you
need to have access to that data not
only is digitalization of your of your
procedures your processes your data
collection not only does that
minimize human error
uh and ensure that you've got that uh
audit ability or that
provenance of the data but it'll also
give you access to that preponderance of
data that you've generated
making your therapeutic and what that
will do is not only allow you to do
things like continued process
verification to make sure that it is
going according to your manufacturing
process
or or the uh acceptance criteria for
that particular product um but it'll
also enable you to do process
improvement where you can say hey
um you know this particular batch was
running a little closer to our
specifications than than normal let's
dig into that let's find out why that is
so you can start
pulling in that data not just internally
but with those collaborators as well
those folks that are in your contract
manufacturing network or your your
contract r d areas there it's a it's a
huge advantage for
for these
for these organizations
it is indeed
you know summarizing a bit what we have
been discussing with
i mean what the which are the key
advantage in using like i.t solution in
sl engine therapy first of all due to
the nature of the manufacturing
facilitating the collaboration between
the different department different
laboratories different entities
it's it's the key you know i mean a good
collaboration means improve in quality
you know
as well that integrity is another big
big advantage of course like i mean
there is a lot of regulatory on cell
engine therapy since i mean we are
talking about the injectable in in the
patients and
be being able to automatically save all
the results automatically save all the
raw data is a really really great
advantage for uh for this reason and
it's removing work from scientists so
the
the big advantage is that scientists can
be much more dedicated to them passion
to them you know
work that is in indeed to do science
that's right you know i've heard from a
lot of uh
former peers uh in industry but also
once you know now i'm in my role at
biovia
and desol system i go to uh prospective
customers or existing customers and like
i i i didn't uh do a phd so i could uh
copy and paste into excel
i'm like i hear you so yeah it's
absolutely bring up those uh very
skilled uh professionals to be able to
focus on the very important work and not
do
non-value-added work
um lastly you know i think one of our
takeaways from this whole talk it's
about
having a holistic view of that process
so from the very beginning of of when
you start narrowing down those
candidates for your therapeutic all the
way through the pre-clinical clinical um
the hospital setting or the caregiver
setting
getting the data from the patient or
excuse me getting the cells and data
from the patient and bringing it uh
completely through
the process um being able to understand
everything so that you can make it all
better more efficient more cost
effective
that is one of the
the key reasons we do what we do um and
it uh it really can be a game changer
so and which are like the messages that
we should
take away which are the key takeaway
from this discussion first of all like
the i.t solution can enhance and
facilitate the collaboration efficiency
enhancing efficiency means as well
reducing the cost i mean this is a
really important point cell engine
therapy manufacturing has a very high
cost at the moment so
being able to facilitate this workflow
means like reducing of course the cost
and a lot of costs are well as well
dedicated to that integrity you know
think about saving all of the raw data
saving all the
log files all the important
data for compliance is taking a lot of
effort in time and money of course so
being able to do this in automatic
manner is a huge huge advantage for uh
for the for the engine therapy
manufacturing definitely
and certainly uh bringing a digital
um paradigm to all of this work that
happens
uh from the early discovery phases
through to uh collecting cells from the
patient bringing it to the clinical
space or when it has to be scaled up and
brought back to the patient
having a holistic view of all of the
data that's generated throughout that
process
it affords uh not only continuous
improvement so that you can understand
hey this particular batch is uh we're
running closer to our uh our design
criteria closer to our control limits
than we wanted let's investigate and see
how we can make this better so you've
got that continuous improvement element
but what that also allows you to do when
you have access to all of that data
it allows flexibility which is
absolutely critical for cell and gene
therapeutic
because
either that condition or that patient
population there's a lot of variability
in there
you need to be able to adjust as you go
having all of those
be digital
it's more efficient sometimes not even
possible if you're just using paper or
silo data system so having everything
integrated
allows for that flexibility and again
that flexibility affords
efficiency and
savings
and with that that concludes the
presentation portion of the session so i
think we're ready to move on to our q a
thanks so much for your attention
looking forward to your questions
thank you
thank you chris and domenico for your
informative presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor dassault system for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions as a
reminder any questions submitted today
and during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye